sosa schweinehaltung in deutschland
früher mal aus und so sieht
schweinehaltung heute noch aus für mich
ist das eine masse und deswegen sozial
und manchmal sieht schweinehaltung
leider auch so aus vielleicht haben sie
sogar glück werden sie direkt erschlagen
werden nach ihrer geburt frontal wurde
dieses material exklusiv zugespielt und
wir müssen euch waren diese bilder sind
nicht leicht zu ertragen
aber wir werden ihnen im laufe des films
auf den grund gehen
ich bin ganz fest davon überzeugt dass
das etwas ist dass zukünftige
generationen in dieser raum nicht
nachvollziehen
100 schweine auf der weide sind ganz
tolle geschichte aber ich werde meine
familie von mähren könnt billiges
fleisch hat seinen preis
wir fragen uns warum werden schweine
2020 immer noch so gehalten
das ist dirk nienhaus er ist
konventioneller landwirt und hält rund
3500 schweine in seinen ställen und er
macht etwas das für bauern eher
ungewöhnlich ist er setzt voll auf
transparenz und zeigt sein betrieb von
innen auf instagram nimmt er seine
follower mit auf seinem hof und zeigt
konventionelle schweinehaltung 2020 so
entsteht 99 prozent des deutschen
schweinefleisches er hat über 26.000
follower auf instagram
ja das ist das zeigt mir das ist ein
riesenbedarf da die leute wollen weniger
wissen wie nix das lebenswerk stellt
seit 15 jahren arbeitet dirk nienhaus
schon als schweinebauer in bocholt sein
betrieb ist eher klein mit 3500 ihren
dass solche massen in der
schweinehaltung heute standard sind
schockiert viele konsumenten
das garantiere allerdings günstige
fleischpreise sagt dirk nienhaus
weil der verbraucher diese vorstellung
von der von der weide von dem teil auf
den tieren auf der anderen seite gibt
diese brutalen hülsen bilder von
einschlägigen organisationen und die
prein aufeinander und bei genauso einer
einschlägigen organisation arbeitet
sandra franz
sie ist pressesprecherin der
tierschutzorganisation animal rights
watch die tierhaltung wie sie heutzutage
standardmäßig praktiziert wird ist die
absolute hölle für die tiere
aber das ist halt das resultat davon
wenn man fleisch zu zu preisen sozusagen
anbieten möchte dass sich viele menschen
reisten können dann ist so nett hier
haltung einfach die feuerwehr auch
dieses material wurde animal rights
watch zugespielt es sind bisher
unveröffentlichte aufnahmen aus einem
stall in sachsen
die bilder sind ende juni dieses jahres
entstanden ferkel werden totgeschlagen
zähne werden abgeschliffen schweine in
viel zu engen kastenständen gehalten
damit solche missstände überhaupt an die
öffentlichkeit gelangen brechen
tierschützer immer wieder in stelle ein
darüber gibt es massiven streit zwischen
tierschützern landwirten und der politik
die bundesregierung hat sogar im
aktuellen koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
stall einbrüche sollen härter bestraft
werden kurz vorweg es ist kein einbruch
also das ist ein hausfriedensbruch und
da auch ein sehr milder
hausfriedensbruch weil in steyl gebäude
eingedrungen wird und nicht in wohnhaus
in unseren augen hat die öffentlichkeit
ein recht darauf zu wissen wie diese
tiere leben müssen das ist natürlich
mittlerweile eine tolle geschichte
geworden
diese bilder dieser weise zu beschaffen
ich finde trotzdem einfach scheiße weil
es geht so sehr ins persönlichkeitsrecht
rein und ich kenne auch betriebe wo es
schon passiert ist und ich bin da
relativ hart gesotten manche sind da
sehr besaitet und und diarra nach recht
stressig stall zu gehen
madeleine martin ist
tierschutzbeauftragte in hessen vor
allem aber war sie früher selbst
amtstierärztin und hat kontrollen
durchgeführt wir zeigen ihr die uns
vorliegenden aufnahmen der
tierschutzorganisation
wir legen hier mit den gezeigten kaarst
bestand breiten weit unter allen
üblichen werden
da ist die frage war die verwaltung da
waren die weiteren herr da werden sie da
war warum haben sie nicht gehandelt
wenn sie gehandelt haben ist die nächste
stufe
ein externer einfluss genommen nehmen
schweinebauern einfluss auf staatliche
kontrollen gibt es bestechung kaum
vorstellbar und doch hat die
tierschutzbeauftragte so etwas erlebt
ich kann aus meiner erfahrung sagen sie
werden so oft mit solchen bitten
konfrontieren das kann sich
wahrscheinlich die bevölkerung gar nicht
verstanden welche behörde ist denn
zuständig für den hof von dem unsere
undercover bilder stammen unsere suche
führt uns nach geschützt hier in diesem
ort zwischen leipzig und dresden sind
die bilder in einem ferkel stahl
entstanden über google maps finden wir
ein ferkel mester hierbei handelt es
sich jedoch nicht um den aktuellen
betreiber wie wir später herausfinden
doch zuerst fragen wir beim zuständigen
veterinäramt hat es nicht genau genug
hingeschaut
die behörde antwortet die letzte
kontrolle dieser anlage erfolgt im mai
dieses jahres schwer erkrankte schweine
wurden zum kontroll zeitpunkt nicht im
bestand vorgefunden die
tierschutzrechtlichen kontrollen ergaben
allerdings mängel an den haltungs
einrichtungen deren abstellungen sofort
beauftragt wurden
eine weitere kontrolle wird durchgeführt
schweinehaltung hinter gittern ist seit
jahren ein problem in der
konventionellen haltung oft viel zu eng
und eine qual für die tiere doch
kastenstände und ferkelschutzkorb sind
grundsätzlich erlaubt eine sau verbringt
fast die hälfte ihres lebens in
gitterboxen
im deck zentrum dort wo die sauen besamt
werden stehen sie bis zu vier wochen in
kastenständen im abwehrbereich kommen
die fährte zur welt hier leben die so
noch mal bis zu fünf wochen im
sogenannten ferkelschutzkorb die bauern
sagen
das schützt die ferkel damit sie nicht
von der muttersau erdrückt werden
das bundesverwaltungsgericht hat längst
entschieden eine sau muss sich im
kastenstand ungehindert ausstrecken
können
dafür muss der kasten stand so breit
sein wie das tier hoch ist so weit die
theorie in der praxis gelten weiter
ausnahmeregelung und übergangsfristen
auch für dirk nienhaus ist
schweinehaltung hinter gittern
eigentlich überholt trotzdem arbeitet er
nach wie vor mit ferkelschutzkorb können
damit leben wir können nämlich relativ
in der ferkel leben retten
nur die akzeptanz findet komplett das
merken wir auch gesellschaftlich einfach
nicht mehr tragbar das ding
die kritik an den kastenständen ist
wirklich nicht neu zu eng seien diese
metallkästen und so lange würden die
sound darin fixiert die
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin julia
klöckner kündigte ende 2019
verbesserungen an
die frage stellt sich immer wie ist der
aktuelle gesetzliche standard wir werden
bei der kasten haltung einiges ändern
doch das gesetz das die ministerin noch
im selben monat vorlegt ändert fast
nicht
der bundesrat soll zustimmen dass der
kasten stand für weitere 17 jahre bleibt
wie er ist sogar der deutsche ethikrat
attackiert die ministerin
obwohl der sich selten zu tier themen
äußert es ist natürlich so dass man das
landwirtschaftsministerium auch die
interessen der landwirtschaft also
ökonomische interessen zu vertreten hat
und die schwierigkeit der aktuellen
politik sich vor allen dingen daran dass
sie versucht das alles so mit einer
konsenssoße zu übergießen und so zu tun
als ob er tatsächlich alles miteinander
vereinbaren können strom kommt aus der
dose und das gespannt aus der kühltheke
das funktioniert eben so
am ende scheitert klöckner mit ihrem
vorschlag der kompromiss zwischen ihr
und den ländern die kastenstände bleiben
vorerst aber die bauern müssen langsam
umstellen wer in den nächsten fünf
jahren nicht anfängt muss seinen stall
schließen umbauten kosten viel geld für
viele landwirte ein problem
uns fehlt aktuell die klare perspektive
und auch die klare das klare bekenntnis
auch mal auf dem verbraucher dass er
sagt ja ich bin jetzt bereits bräuchten
ein höheres geld zu zahlen das visum auf
maßnahmen finanzieren könnten
die richtung muss klar sein hinzu mir
tierwohl aber auch mehr wertschätzung
und da sind wir alle in einem boot auch
der verbraucher ist nicht nur der
tierhalter es ist total billig von
politikern die fahrt die verantwortung
auf die konsumenten abzuschieben
dieses system ist politisch gewollt
dieses system hat seine profiteure die
kunden und die bekommen billiges fleisch
rund 36 kilogramm ist der
durchschnittsdeutsche und billig fleisch
aus deutschland ist längst ein
exportschlager geworden
2,4 millionen tonnen wurden im letzten
jahr exportiert 500.000 tonnen gingen
davon nach china so viel wie noch nie
und mit 55 millionen geschlachteten
schweinen pro jahr ist deutschland auf
platz drei der weltweiten
schweinefleisch produkten
da wird geld reingepumpt und es wird
alles dafür getan dass es einfach so
weitergeht und die politiker sind die
die dieses system ändern können 1950
hielt ein bauer im schnitt fünf schweine
heute sind es durchschnittlich 1175
schweine pro betrieb
immer mehr schweine bei immer weniger
bauern
für kostengünstiges match zurück zu den
bildern aus sachsen wir wollen mit den
verantwortlichen sprechen
wieso werden in seinem betrieb ferkel
totgeschlagen warum müssen die sauen in
zu kleinen kastenständen stehen warum
das ziel abgreifen über verschiedene
handelsregister auszüge finden wir den
zuständigen betreiber heraus johann
fanden born
der stall hat den besitzer gewechselt
und gehört jetzt zur firma tier gut
elbland wir finden einen zeitungsartikel
von 2017
darin geht es um den stall umbau im
geschützen johann fanden born gibt sich
hier als jemand dem das tier wohl sehr
am herzen liegt außerdem müssen künftig
die beamten seien laut tierschutzgesetz
in gruppen von etwa 30 tieren gehalten
werden dafür wird mehr platz benötigt
wir wollen dem gesetz vorgreifen und
schon jetzt diese forderung umsetzen so
van bommel
wie passt seine aussage mit diesen
bildern zusammen hier haben die sauen
weniger platz als es ihnen gesetzlich
zustehen und wieso werden ferkel nicht
ordnungsgemäß betäubt sondern auf dem
boden tot geschlagen
wir kontaktieren den betreiber und
bitten um ein interview
johann fanden borner lehnt dies ab
da niemand mit uns reden will
fahren wir zu uns bekannten adresse wir
möchten uns ein bild vom ort des
geschehens machen
in der hauptzentrale wirbt die firma mit
diesem schild kontrolliertes
qualitätsfleisch 30 kilometer weiter am
stall ingo schütz treffen wir niemanden
an
wir finden eine telefonnummer am tor
aber auch hier ist niemand zu erreichen
auf der anderen seite treffen wir dann
auf einen mitarbeiter
gibt es jemand
wir sind mein name ist wohl eher vom zdf
das geht um gewisse vorwürfe gegen das
tierschutzgesetz hier in diesem stein
verstoßen wird
aber ist
auf schriftliche anfragen antwortet
betreiber fanden bornen nicht die
vorgaben für die nutztierhaltung sind
eigentlich ganz klar im tierschutzgesetz
geregelt § 1 niemand darf einem tier
ohne vernünftigen grund schmerzen leiden
oder schäden zufügen
der fall galt schütz zeigt nur mit
bildern von tierschützern erfährt die
öffentlichkeit wie groß das leid der
tiere hinter verschlossenen stalltüren
sein kann
ein schweine system wo es wirklich hängt
sind die verschiedenen akteure und da
muss ich leider natürlich auch die
amtsärztin und amtsärzte nochmal
erwerben
sie sind garanten für den verzug und das
ehrenamtlich tätige oder in vereinen
tätig ein brechen müssen in strömen
das ist in meinen augen ein skandal wird
mein haus glaubt zu große stelle zu
große tierfabriken seien das eigentliche
problem dann wenn der bauer sein schwein
nicht mehr kennt dann wünsche ich mir
auch ganz klar dass es rechtliche
rahmenbedingungen gibt die es auch
ermöglichen so dass man wieder diese
kleine statur wieder aufbaut das ist
wieder sexy wird im kleinen
beschaulichen rahmen tiere für den
regionalen markt zu zu schlachten das
ist einfach gesetzlich gar nicht nötig
für die tierschützer von arriva reicht
das nicht
natürlich kann sich jeder einzelne dafür
entscheiden dass nicht mehr zu kaufen
und was anderes zu kaufen aber damit
sich wirklich was ändert da muss die
politik eingreifen und wir sehen jetzt
auch nicht die lösung darin dass die
tiere mehr platz bekommen oder ein
bisschen stroh sondern in unseren augen
muss die politik eine radikale
agrarwende fördern und das ist eine
agrarwende hin zu pflanzen basierten
landwirtschaft die komplett ohne
nutztierhaltung aus grund und die im
nach biologischen prinzipien basiert
eine radikale forderung
denn nur knapp zehn prozent der
deutschen ernährt sich ohne fleisch der
rest will flash viele möglichst billig
und dabei am besten artgerecht gerecht
werden würde würde ich mein liebster
feind waren und das gerät das mit
sophies leben kann
kommen sie nicht beeinflusst ich spreche
gerne hier vom tiergerecht schwein kennt
das leben draußen sich das schwein kennt
es um drin zu sein
das ist meine definition von von von
gerechtigkeit was findet ihr gerecht
sollte fleisch teurer werden damit es
den schweinen besser geht oder lieber
ganz auf fleisch verzichten schreibt es
uns in die kommentare
[Musik]